hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's all
find the duplicate number and you can
see that i'm not
really a big fan of this problem and
maybe i'm just salty but i really feel
like this type of problem
is the ultimate test of whether you've
seen the problem or not
but i'm still solving it nonetheless
because it's an interesting problem
and it does show up in interviews quite
a lot it seems i really don't know how
anyone would be able to solve this
problem in a 30 minute interview without
having seen even the person who came up
with
the algorithm floyd i i doubt even he
could solve this in 30 minutes in an
interview setting
but that's okay let's just learn the
problem today so we're given an
integer array of nums containing n
plus one integers this is the length of
the array but
every single value in the array is going
to be within the range
one through n so we have n different
values that could be in the array like n
different
choices for the integers but we have n
plus
one integers so that kind of implies
that at least
one of the numbers is going to be
repeated and they tell us that
actually it's only one number is
guaranteed to be repeated
and the only thing we want to do is
return the number that
is repeated more than once now the easy
way to solve this problem of course
would just be have a hash set right
iterate through every single value
find the one that occurs twice by using
our hash set that's going to be o of n
time and o of n memory but they tell us
that we can only use constant extra
space
and we can't even modify the input array
so we can't even sort it or anything
and i think those restrictions probably
make this a hard problem rather than a
medium problem but that's okay
so there's two aspects to this problem
and i'm going to explain both of them so
we're going to solve this in o of n time
and o of 1 space the first thing to
recognize is this is a
linked list problem specifically a
linked list
cycle problem and the second thing is
to know floyd's algorithm which will
tell you the beginning of a cycle in a
linked list so there's two problems one
to even
recognize that this is a linked list
problem and two to know the algorithm to
actually apply to it
once you know that so let me actually
show you how we can
we can figure out both of these things
and yeah you're right it's probably not
super intuitive and i i'm not really
sure how you would be able to figure it
out on your own if you've never done
something like this before
so remember that the length of our array
is n plus 1
but every value in the array is going to
be between
one and n so there's n different values
but there's n plus one positions so in
this
array we have five different elements
right and we know that the elements are
going to be in the range
one through four right so basically
instead of thinking of these as
values let's think of them as pointers
so we know for sure that every single
value
in the array is going to be in the range
one through four that means
if we considered every value as a
pointer
each value is going to point at some
position
in this block of four you can see that
this one
points at position one this three
points at position three this
two points at position two over here
and this four points at position
four over here and then this two points
back at position four so that's how you
can kind of see that
you know in that case there was a cycle
and you can see i basically drew out the
linked list
version of that so it's not hard to see
that this portion is going to form
a cycle because no matter what value we
look at it's going to point at
some other value inside of this range
there's never going to be an
exit condition none of these values are
going to point outside of the range
either you know over here or over here
none of them are going to point
outside of the range so this portion is
going to form a cycle
linked list somewhere right what about
this
value is this going to be a part of the
cycle
notice how none of these values nothing
is
ever going to point at index 0 because
remember our
range is between 1 through 4 none of
them is going to be zero so
none of them is going to point here so
we can guarantee that this
is not going to be a part of the cycle
and when you see i
took this array drew it as a linked list
you can see
this is index zero right you can see
that this was our cycle portion
but this was not included in the cycle
and that's going to be very important
because we do when we start traversing
this linked list we're always going to
start here
because we know this is not a part of
the cycle
so in our input array you can see that 2
is the duplicate right 2
is the one that shows up multiple times
so in the context of this problem
this position is going to point at index
and this position is going to also point
at index two
so what does that tell us about our
linked list
that means at the node that's labeled
two
the each value of the node each label is
going to map to the index so this
is basically node two right what that
tells us about
node two is that multiple nodes are
going to be
pointing to node two right therefore
we know that this is the one that's
going to be the start of the cycle
we know for sure there's going to be a
cycle and we know for sure there's going
to be a portion before the cycle
the portion before the cycle of course
is eventually going to lead us to here
which is the start
of the cycle and of course there's going
to be another node that completes the
cycle right putting it back
pointing back to this node so if we can
somehow identify the beginning of a
cycle
in this linked list then we will know
that that beginning of the cycle
is the return value that we're looking
for in the output you can see yes
2 is the duplicate that's the one we
want to return therefore we want to
return the start of the cycle
so at this point it's all about applying
floyd's algorithm to find the beginning
of a cycle
so that's once you've determined that
it's a linked list problem then you just
need to apply
this algorithm and this algorithm itself
is actually also not very intuitive
so let's look at a slightly different
example so i can illustrate the
floyd's algorithm so first i'm just
going to tell you what the algorithm is
and then i'm going to explain a little
bit of the intuition of why it actually
works
so the slow pointer and fast pointer are
both going to start at this position
the slow pointer of course is going to
be shifted by one
each iteration so that's one jump that's
two jumps that's three jumps so we just
made three jumps with our
with our slow pointer let's do the exact
same thing with our fast pointer
so remember a jump with the fast pointer
is going to be two positions so that's
one jump that's two jumps
and let's make two more jumps from here
so we're gonna go to two
and then back to three so you can see
that it got a little bit
messy but we made three jumps with the
fast pointer and we made three jumps
with a slow pointer and you can see
this is the first position that they
intersected at
so this was the intersection of
the us of the two pointers right this
was the first
intersection so that's the first phase
of this algorithm first we find the
first position that they intersect at
then we take our slow pointer leave it
here
so our slope pointer is going to be here
right and then we're going to be done
with the fast pointer we're going to
take a
second slow pointer and put it right at
the beginning of the array
and each of these slow pointers we're
gonna keep shifting them by
one until they intersect one more time
so
this slow pointer is going to be shifted
by one this slow pointer is also going
to be shifted by one
hey and we just found out that they
intersected right
and this second point of intersection is
always going to be the result it's not
intuitive at all
why this is the case yet but let me
explain that but now you know the
algorithm if all you wanted to do was
memorize it that's literally it now you
can code it up
that's why i don't like this problem
because it's simple if you
if you've solved it before so this
algorithm relies on the fact that the
intersection point like the first
intersection between the two pointers
the distance between this point and the
beginning of the cycle which in this
case
is one right is always going to be the
same as the starting point
distance from the cycle from the start
of the cycle that's also
one right since we know that's the case
that's how we can take two slow pointers
start one here start one here and then
keep shifting until they intersect
then we get the result but why is it the
case that the distance between this
is the same as the distance between this
looking at this bigger example why is it
that
the distance between the start and to
the start of the cycle
is always going to be the same between
the intersection and the start of the
cycle why is that the case well let's
just draw out a few
distances let's say the distance this
is p right basically p is the number of
previous nodes we have before the actual
start of the cycle
and let's just say you know arbitrarily
this is this the
intersection point between the two
points right and we don't know that this
is going to be the same so let's just
label it
x for noun let's not label it p so
because we don't know for sure that it's
going to be the same
let's label it x this is our unknown and
then
the remaining portion of the cycle
is going to be c which is the length of
the cycle right in this case it's 5
minus x right because the total cycle
is is 5 which is c and this this x
portion makes up the remaining portion
of the cycle that's why the
this part is c minus x so we know that
the slow pointer is going to start at
the beginning it's going to traverse
this p
portion and then it's going to traverse
the c minus x portion and it's going to
land
at the intersection point right now we
know
that the fast pointer is going to do
more than that it's going to of course
do this p portion
once then it's going to do a complete
loop right because remember the fast
pointer is going to
out loop the slow pointer and it's going
to overlap the slow pointer so it's
going to have to complete
a full at least one full loop
and then once it does a full loop it's
going to be back here
and then it's going to traverse this c
minus x
portion to get to the intersection point
right we don't know where the
intersection is
obviously i drew it over here but it
could be anywhere so let's
write that mathematical equation out so
we know that
two times the number of iterations the
slow pointer does is
equal to the number of iterations the
fast pointer does right how many
spaces it moves versus how many spaces
the slow pointer moves of course
the fast one is twice as fast that's why
we have to multiply the slow one by two
to make it equal to this one and how
many
iterations did we say that the fast one
does it's going to do p
plus c x right to get to this position
and then it's going to do another
complete
cycle starting from here to get back to
this position right
so the fast pointer is going to be p
plus c minus x
plus c again so more simplified it's
going to be
p plus 2c minus x
the the slope pointer is just going to
do p and then it's
just going to do c minus x so we'll have
a 2 on the outside
p plus c minus
x so i'm going to take this equation and
simplify it over here to the right
so once we simplify it a little bit
we're going to get 2p
plus 2c minus 2x which is
equal to p plus 2c
minus x and then this is the part where
you can start doing a little bit of
algebra so we can cross out the 2c from
both sides of the equation we can cross
out one x
from each side of the equation and we
can cross out one p
from each side of the equation once we
do that algebra we're left with the
equation and sorry that it's getting a
little bit messy we're left with a
single p
and a single negative x so we get p
minus x
is equal to notice how we crossed out
everything on the right side so we got p
minus x is equal to zero when we
rearrange that we get
p is equal to zero what did we just
prove we just proved that the
pre-portion of the cycle is always equal
to
this right so that's how we know
once we have a pointer over here then we
can set another slow pointer over here
keep iterating them by one and for sure
when they
meet they're going to meet at the inner
at the start
of the cycle they're always going to
meet at this position so i hope this
explains a little bit of the intuition
and a little bit of how you know this is
very rigorous this is a proof this is
always going to work
and now you know why it's always going
to work but the code is actually really
simple
now one last thing i didn't mention
before we dive into the code is that
notice how this p
this pre-portion could be really long
it could be even longer than the entire
length of the cycle so how would that
update our math would our math still
work out in that case
and i didn't include this in the math
because i don't want to over complicate
it too much
but yes the math would work instead of
having
2c over here we would have an n over
here
and the math would end up still working
out basically we would always start back
at the beginning here
we traverse this many nodes and then
from here
basically instead of just traveling this
small distance it could be possible that
we would have to do multiple
loops you know because if this distance
was really long
longer than the length of this loop we
would have to do multiple loops but
after all of that the remainder would
still be
this portion left so we would still end
up getting to this position
the enter the start of the loop okay now
we can finally get into the code
so remember we're gonna be starting at
phase one of this algorithm we're gonna
have two pointers fast and slow they're
always gonna start at zero remember
because we know
zero is not a part of the cycle that's
for sure
and we're gonna keep iterating through
these loops i think there's an easier
way to write this code but i'm lazy so
just while true
we're going to and we start out with
while true because we want to keep going
until they intersect but notice how they
already intersect at the beginning
so we're going to update slow so
basically slow is going to be
set to whatever it points at so nums of
slow right and then fast is going to be
the opposite or the same thing numbs of
fast but remember
we're advancing fast twice and so we can
just do this and of course
fast and slow are always going to be
inbounds right they're never going to
point out of bounds we know that for
sure based on the restrictions that
we're given
and if slow is equal to fast that's when
we can break
out of the loop if they're not equal
then we're not going to break this is
basically a do while loop
but i don't think you can do that in
python so once we've done this
that's how we know okay fast and slow
intersected here
so now we're going to create a second
slow pointer slow 2
we're going to set it to the beginning
right back at index 0
and now we're going to keep incrementing
this slow pointer and the first slow
pointer until they intersect so this is
phase two of the algorithm while true
advance the slow pointer by one
and advance the second slow pointer by
one as well notice how trivial this code
is the hard part is just figuring it out
so when we're going to keep going until
they intersect so
if these were equal then we can break
out
of this loop and then return
the slow pointer right we can return
either of them slow one or slow two
index that they're at right slow slow
one and slow two are always an index and
the index that they're at
is the duplicate number because we have
multiple values pointing to the same
value that's the duplicate we can
actually take this and return it here
so i'm just going to go ahead and do
that and this is the entire solution
okay i don't know what i was thinking i
don't know why i put fast on the outside
this is nums
nums of fast which is a number which is
a different index and then we're going
to use that same index again
in the nums array that's how we're
basically advancing fast by two we could
obviously write it in different lines of
code but i'm just gonna leave it as it
is just because it's a little bit neater
and also i don't i don't really know
what i'm thinking but the slow
the second slow pointer also needs to be
advanced i don't know why i called it
slow one but that is the entire code
and then once they finally meet we are
going to be returning that index
and as you can see the solution does
work it's in a linear time solution
we definitely didn't need to use any
extra space we didn't need to modify the
input array
this is the floyd's algorithm with a
fast and slow pointer
beginning of a cycle detection so i hope
that this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching